I'm at the John F Kennedy Library here
in Boston and I'm walking around we just
watch a video and I read this about him
you know sometimes you think you know a
person who becomes a president or a
successful CEO they must have done
everything right growing up look at this
see if we can see this in high school he
was an underachiever with a rebel streak
his shenanigans a mediocre grades
exasperated his father who feared his
son might not have bound to much think
about that and then he go over here and
look what his house master John Mayer
said about him in school
Jack's studies at the last minute keeps
appointments late has little sense of
material value and can seldom locate his
possessions can seldom locate his
possession does this sound like their
president you and I look what happens
over here this is what his father says
to him this is now Jack I definitely
know you have the goods and he can go a
long way I will not be disappointed if
you don't turn out to be a real genius
but I think you can be a real worthwhile
really worthwhile citizen with good
judgment and misunderstand understanding
it's not always who you think it's gonna
do something big with their lives dead
ends up doing it sometimes it's the
underdog that no one pays attention to
who never had any plans that remember
running for office who never had any
plans that being a president that ends
up becoming one of the most popular
presidents of all time who made a big
impact and that's John F Kennedy so if
you don't have the most incredible
resume you may be fully qualified to do
something big with your life